the jurogan experience i watched uh
restrepo
last night
because of what's going on in
afghanistan do you do you know restrepo
sebastian younger's uh film on
afghanistan
yeah just sort of um
just put it in perspective like what's
going on over there now and um
it's
you know i mean books are amazing for
putting things into perspective but
there's something about a documentary
especially a boots on the ground
documentary by a journalist like
sebastian younger
and in afghanistan while afghanistan is
falling to the taliban so it feels so
it's so intense when you're watching it
and you see you know guys in the
beginning of the film that wind up dying
and
it's uh
first of all i i forgot
like i think you you have a sense of
what
they mean when they talk about these
mountainous
areas this mountainous terrain that's
impossible really to control because
it's very difficult to traverse very
difficult to get around i don't think
you really understand it until you watch
that film
until you really see the mountains and
you're like oh god like how is anybody
ever going to control this area
like no wonder why the soviets failed no
wonder why we failed no wonder why
you know the people that live there
they just
they're living in
an incredibly difficult environment in
terms of like just getting around
yeah i remember some statistics about
like 99 of people in afghanistan
know it's not like brian cowan
afghanistan
uh
uh iran iran yeah i never know how to
say it
i remember like 99 of them didn't know 9
11 happened
so like they're completely disconnected
from the world even
that's so crazy that like even things
that seem relevant
too did you watch the videos today of
people trying to climb aboard planes and
falling to their deaths the planes are
taken off these guys are hanging onto
the landing gear and as the landing gear
pulls up they're falling to their death
trying to save themselves yes trying to
leave with the americans
it's
[ __ ] crazy just the chaos at the
airport is cr you haven't seen any of
this i haven't seen i i actually have
not been paying attention jamie show him
some of the the videos because it's
it's heartbreaking
yeah these are people just literally
climbing all over these ladders doing
whatever they can trying to force
themselves onto these planes and but the
really [ __ ] one is like look these
guys hanging
on the landing gear watch this like
falling to his death
it's [ __ ]
yeah and look at this i mean [ __ ]
crazy all these guys trying to stop the
plane
so they can get on board
i mean this is just a
tremendous failure
it's so heartbreaking yeah but what do
you do
what could be done differently right
that's the real question like could have
uh
could they have
designed uh a better withdrawal plan
that
scaled over time
where they gave uh particularly the
people that
helped
the american military over there that
they're very vulnerable right now and
they're they're in a lot of trouble
could they have protected them better
could they have done something could
they have designed a plan that's what
most people who are criticizing this
believe the people that actually
understand what's going on over there
they think this idea of pulling out
immediately
yeah but half the world is living under
authoritarian regimes
so the question is how do you help those
people how do you help you had a nice
sophisticated deep historical
conversation with andrew schultz about
north korea
but outs are you being sarcastic that's
a little bit of sarcasm there i i love
him he's hilarious and i'm just joking
he is hilarious but he was uh he was
going hard to paint yeah a little bit
but he's but like how do you help he's
having fun well the the the crit
the one sort of uh sophisticated
criticism there was well what the hell
do you do about it right what do you do
about north korea well
what
and there's a lot of places like that
and north korea is probably the worst or
one of the worst but there's a lot of
places where the leader the government
is abusing its people what do you do
about it the uh the whole cryptocurrency
bitcoin people say
maybe you can change the money
you can give people power by
like one of the ways government controls
its people is the monetary system so you
can like swap out
try to give people power through the
money that's one way that's interesting
uh the obviously the old school way is
military
uh and
or also maybe economic pressures but
then it becomes
it becomes difficult because you're
taking on that project and then you get
the thing that you get in afghanistan
and
you know it's a project that takes 10
years it takes 20 years and then
ultimately it's not successful so the
afghanistan situation is so crazy
because uh you know biden was on
television just a little while ago
talking about how there's 300 000
armed afghanistan soldiers that were
trained by the united states and there's
only 75 000 taliban there's no way
that they're going to fall but they
never fought they just gave up like
instantly
yeah
right you know it's like the whole
situation is very confusing to someone
who doesn't understand it
if you're
if you're a guy who fought over there
too it's got to be insanely frustrating
people spilled blood over there people
lost limbs over there and then they're
seeing how quickly we just pulled out an
abandoned ship like what
what was
what was that for
well we got into that war under false
pretenses
we stayed without much transparency
about why we're staying how many 20
[ __ ] years yeah without without a
clear plan for the future
and then we pulled out without a clear
transparent plan
yeah hey what but i don't know what
lesson to draw from that except that we
should never gone in in the first place
that's that's the only sort of
solid set of arguments you can have
because and like why that place you know
it's the people that argue is all about
oil and all those kinds of things and
minerals and minerals all sorts of
natural resources right natural gas
like afghanistan is a
it's a rich suppository of lithium i
believe too right
yeah natural but then what about iraq
like what does that have to do with
anything and so
you start
you start questioning the whole
operation the whole process of making
decisions about foreign policy in the
military conflicts
you know what lesson do you draw from
that when there's places like north
korea when there's many people in in
africa suffering there's many regimes
that are abusing its people
there
then then there's people that criticize
russia
uh for for for certain things in terms
of from an authoritarian regime
perspective and then the big one is
china and then what do you do about that
and then i i mean i do find the
libertarian argument here
the most sophisticated and convincing is
we should
stay out
of other people's business until we have
a really clear good plan and
you know the majority of americans
uh given a transparent communication of
what is going on and what we're going to
do majority of americans uh are behind
this plan otherwise stay out of it
unless you have
you know that you know when you have
like uh something like a nazi germany
where there's obvious atrocities uh
happening where there's an obvious war
on the horizon then that's different but
everything well if that's the case and
why aren't we invading north korea
if wyoming park and all these different
people that have escaped from north
korea are telling the truth that there's
a holocaust going on there right now
i mean they're they're literally
starving their people they're putting
their people in concentration camps
they're having children born in
concentration camps for the crimes of
their grandparents
and their children will also be born in
these camps in these prison camps
they're starving their people they
execute them for
you know almost no reason they do
whatever they want to them they have
full and total complete control over
them
well the dark
answer
and the reason is because there's no way
to do anything about north korea without
also doing something about china yeah
and that's
that's why we turn
a blind eye to north korea because
um i mean that's a deeply i mean a war
with north korea or invasion of north
korea is an invasion of china watch the
entire episode for free only on spotify